This is FRESH AIR. Our guest Neil Gaiman's introduced his horror fantasy
comic The Sandman in one thousand nine hundred nine it attracted a large adult audience.
Norman Mailer described it as a comic strip for
intellectuals its hero was a godlike creature known as dream or
Morpheus he was named one of the endless A group of seven immortal
siblings each named for what they embodied desire despair
delerium destruction destiny and death.
Gaiman's Sandman stories dealt with mortals and gods alike and were considered
groundbreaking for the time the seventy five issue series ended in one thousand nine hundred six. But
for its twenty fifth anniversary game in return to write a six part mini series that's
just been collected in one volume called The Sandman Overture.
Neil Gaiman's has also written many bestselling books for adults and children
including American Gods. Coraline and Stardust the last two were made into movies.
He spoke with FRESH AIR producer Sam
Berger near game and welcome to FRESH AIR.
Thank you so much.
So you hear a Sandman is known by many names. Some of those are dream or Morpheus and
he's and charge he's the Lord of the dream world. He's a personification of
the act of dreaming can you describe his activities for us.
The upon a
miscarriage of Sandman I decided that he would be really interesting
to create a character who was dream who was
the in connotation of the act of dreaming. He's one of
a family of seven siblings beginning with destiny and
death and ending with despair and delirium.
He is incredibly
stiff slightly pompous rather lonely hidebound and obsessed
by rules. And has very little
sense of himself.
He is many many things but empathetic is not really one of
them although he slightly softer than he likes to believe himself to be.
And he's not very
funny he really is which is
always one of those things I enjoy because it allows me to have other characters around
him being funny.
So you said the Sandman is part of a family that you call the endless these immoral
siblings whose names can be only start with the letter D. there's death. Desire
despair destiny destruction delirium and dream. So they're
like gods but
they function and exist differently than the other guys in your book
your books your comics are populated with all sorts of
gods because their existence doesn't rely on faith. Can you explain that a little
more. I love the idea that basically gods rely on worship.
They rely on
belief out there in the world wherein you can tell the
importance of any day or two by how many temples they have how
many worshippers they have in the real world and. I assume it's the
same on whatever godly stretch out there
on the endless simply exist they don't care if you believe
in them or not they are these anthropomorphic personifications
of fundamental things to do with life and they are doing
their
job so because we dream because we despair
because we desire they they exist as a function of those things
are exactly the idea was that Destiny came into existence just
before there was any life death came into existence as
there was life because life now contains the potential for
death. And so on and. Really a lot of it went
back to when I started writing Sandman back
in one thousand nine hundred seventy. I began to write it I was thinking that there really
just weren't any comics out there
with families and and I love family dynamics
I love the way that families work or don't work I love the way that
families behave I love the way the families interact and it seems like that would
be a really fun kind of thing to put in and when I came over to America to
do signings. People would say to me. We
love the Sandman and his family. They're a wonderful dysfunctional
family and it was in the fray said about her before and
I said well hang on Explain to me what is
a dysfunctional family and people would explain. And after a while I realized that what Americans called
a dysfunctional family was what we in England called the
family having never encountered any
functional one
functional your main character Salman as a hero but not a
typical comic book hero you see more of a tragic hero with flaws that
eventually causes
undoing as you said he's arrogant he's humorless he's up tight and just about
the worst person to ever remain to correlation simply he really
is terrible were you careful to make sure that with all of these
flaws he was still likable
enough. No I was perfectly willing for
him to be unlikeable and I think that
somehow what works in his favor. He
is absolutely appalling
sometimes but there's one storyline where you discover
that he'd sentenced essentially an old girlfriend
to hell for ten thousand years basically for pissing him
off and. When this is pointed out to him and
pointed out in that he did the wrong thing he promptly
Nobili heads off into hell to bring her back and try and do the right thing but you have to be
very aware that this is somebody who had
really sent somebody to help the ten thousand years because
she irritated him because she spent him.
Your editor Karen Berger has said that Sandman was the first modern comic that attracted a
large female readership What do you think women responded to in
those comics. I think they responded really really well to the fact that it
wasn't a pre-adolescent male power fantasy.
And it had a lot of women in it it had a lot of active women in it too a part of
the story when I started writing Sandman.
I thought you know I
should probably make sure that I have as many women in
the story as men and that they are
as integral to the
story as the male characters and that was what I tried to do from that
point out sometimes failing sometimes
succeeding and I think that that was the biggest thing that made
it happen. It got very strange for me because I would get.
At conventions large man in sweaty T. shirts coming up to me
and pounding my head
and saying you brought women and my store for the first time.
And I would always have to bite back to say. If you sweep it. They may come back.
But it really was comics back then was a
male
preserve it was male dominated and one of the things I
love now is the fact that there really are as
many female readers of comics and graphic novels as there are
males it is no longer a gender determined medium. Which always seem
to me to be completely bucking mad from the beginning.
I always thought that. Comics were somewhat of a strange art form in that they're they're often
about action and movement and all this kinetic energy yet they're portrayed in static images.
The magic of comics is
that there are three people involved in any comic who's
whoever's writing it and whoever's drawing it and then there's whoever's reading
it because they are creating the movement. They are
creating the illusion of time
passing there's a wonderful moment in Scott McClellan's book
Understanding Comics where he
shows a man standing behind a woman or possibly vice versa.
Rome with an axe and then the next
panel is a carter
way to the building there and a scream.
And he points out that you as a
reader just murdered the character he didn't do it and
that to me is the joy of comics your imagination needs to do an
awful lot.
You're saying Man comics of always been about storytelling and many writers and storytellers have
actually appeared in the pages one of
them is William Shakespeare and he said one of the most famous issues if your run was
about up in the first performance of A Midsummer Night's Dream for an audience of fairies you
also ended the series with issue with
Shakespeare in doubt about whether he had lived his life. Well
because he had spent his life as a writer and he
says whatever happened to me in my life happened to me as a writer of plays I'd fall
in love or fallen
lost and at the height of my passion I would think so this is how it feels and I were tied up in
pretty words I watched my life as if it were happening to some. Else. My
son died and I was hurt but I watched my hurt and even relished it a little for now
I could write a real
death. A true loss. That's a pretty ambivalent description of the writer's
life. I have no idea if that was true for
Shakespeare but I knew that was true for me and wanted
to put that in that it always felt like
the price of being a writer. Was
that you would even in the most terrible moments there was there was a
little phantom the asian of you sitting on your shoulder with a
notebook going I can use this. OK Look at look at look at the way
that the the light is glinting off the broken plastic on the road next
to the blood. You can use this and it was it was a very strange
feeling for me peculiarly I think I kind of exercised it.
Definitely sort of took a step back once a man was done and I
definitely felt like I had taken a step further back into my
life and that just happen naturally you don't have to take certain measures to make
sure you're not too
detached. It definitely happen naturally and maybe it
was part of aging as well and maybe part of it at that time was saying goodbye to
sentiment there was writing Sandman for me was the
most intense period of my
life because the fictional characters were more
real to me or at least as real to me as anything else that was happening.
I was spending more time with them than I was with my own family. I was
you know eight hours a
day I would be sitting huddled over
my computer or scratching still drawings to try and figure
out how to get from one panel to the next or working out the dialogue.
In your same comics you created a whole cosmology that includes. Your own immortal
beings and also all these gods from many different belief systems me you
have Norse gods christian gods Greek
gods Japanese gods. I read that when you were supposed to be studying fear
barmitzvah you could jolt your instructor to tell you non-canonical. Religious
stories. Oh yes when I was I mean that was
the joy for me of religion the stuff that I
loved was
myth. And as a kid my favorite books were things like.
Roger Alonso lingering tales of the Norseman and tales of ancient Egypt
and when I was studying for my Bar Mitzvah. I was
very lucky because I had
a very orthodox Cantor Reverend my
Olive who
I could get off the subject of the stuff that we were meant to be
doing and on to the subject of
wonderful strangest parts of the
Midrash Weird Tales of commentary
and it was essentially although I didn't know it at the time the mythology of Judaism.
It was the stuff that had crept off into the corners that became part of the
oral
tradition and. I loved that I didn't know. When
I was twelve that not everybody knew that for example.
Adam had had three wives. That was his third wife I sort of vaguely assume
that everybody must know that because I've been nice to get on the
subject and that for the record the
first wife was less who then went off and had sex with demons.
So birthmarks it was exactly and spawned. Monsters
and dark creatures.
The second wife was made in front of Adam.
From the bones up. And he got to watch her being created
skin and hair and all and was so revolted by this he wouldn't go near
her which is why God had to put him made her vanish
and put Adam to sleep to create
the so that he wouldn't actually get to see
the creation process and I love that story and.
Then as an adult going to look for it found myself reading so
many obscure books of Jewish mythology until
finally I discovered it I think in a Robert Robert Graves book and when I
hadn't pollution later this I didn't imagine it did actually
exist. Well that idea of us. As a kid listening to all the stories
and stories that are part of the canon it resonates so much
with Sandman and also a lot of the other work where there are
these stories behind the official stories and there's Or there's
always something behind what you're perceiving in
reality I think that for me seems like
a way to talk about the world wherein none of
us exist in a world that is the same world that any of the rest of us live
in the world that's important is the world behind each of our eyes.
Which is something that none of the rest of us can access and more
than that it's the strange impossible bits the idea of
dreaming always fascinates me the idea that even the most normal
people close their eyes for six seven eight hours a night
and during that time. For several hours go. Absolutely and utterly
stark staring mad.
Is beautiful. I think I love my dreaming process because.
One of the things that my dreaming process does is sort on stories for me I will go to
sleep stuck on what happens next I will wake
up somewhere boys in the back room have been
moving heavy furniture around.
They've been digging they've been painting they've been plastering they present it with
the
solution. Well Neil Gaiman's thank you so much for speaking with us today.
Thank you so much. It was wonderful.
Neil Gaiman's spoke with FRESH AIR producer Sam Briger Gaiman's Sandman
twenty fifth anniversary six part mini series is collected in the volume
the Sandman Overture. Tomorrow on FRESH AIR I'll talk with Andrew
Hague the director of the new film forty five years.
It stars Charlotte Rampling and Tom Courtenay as a couple about to celebrate their forty fifth anniversary.
When a secret is revealed that calls into question many of the wife's assumptions about their
marriage. And also directed the film weekend and was the show runner for
the H.B.O. series looking about a group of gay friends in San Francisco
hope you'll join
us FRESH AIR's executive producer is Danny Miller our technical director and
engineers Ferebee is our administrative assistant Our associate producer.
Roberta directs the show. I'm Terry
Gross.